it is terrain which tells the story of
Bordeaux's most famous export this
year's harvest is over now but greats
which grew in this region of France will
have produced wine destined for a global
market bottles will have been ferried to
shops homes and a few placed in this
rocket found for the International Space
Station but have no fear about
astronauts drinking on the job
the wine is strictly off-limits sent
upwards in the name of science only so
these are the canisters like this
they've gone to space absolutely it was
here at the bordeaux scientific
institute of vine and wine that the
bottles were packed in special
containers ready for the mission 12 sent
upwards for a year and 12 left to age on
earth for comparison researchers will
study how space affects the wines
composition and flavor in the hope of
gaining new insights for the food and
drinks industry a beginning we were not
thinking this project was serious but in
fact we took these opportunities that
considering the stay of the wine on this
international special it is a
possibility of studying the impact of
microgravity of the solar radiation onto
the evolution of the wine component
winemaking is a complex process which
uses both yeast and bacteria and
involves chemical processes making a
good for space study according to the
European start-up behind the operation
the launch is the first of six space
missions planned by the company
including sending vines to the ISS the
research could help inform efforts to
breed hard year plants that adapt to
climate change we'll fight off disease
what we really want is to really expose
a number of living organism to the
specific condition of space and bring
them back so you imagine that the the
spectrum of what we expect is going to
be going from being botanist bring back
interesting new evolutions of life in
space that could allow us to get more
resilient plants to specific parasites
they're going to grow with climate
change
getting Bordeaux bottles into space
builds on the rich history of wine in
the region going back centuries at this
Cultural Center they track the evolution
of the product down the decades from
early exports to the modern day and the
ISS mission is certain to take pride of
place here at some points the treasured
beverage helping with science we're
proud because it's part of the culture
it's part of the local culture of the
economy as well and in for years and
centuries wine as has been exported from
Bordeaux and now the exports have gone
further than ever before when the 12
bottles are brought down from space
after a year they'll be tasted and
analyzed the greatest challenge for now
could be keeping the astronauts hands
off them during the festive period a
shelter at Sky News Gordon